las vegas has always been known as the
marriage capital of the world
and as we continue to battle a global
pandemic we've seen a marriage boom from
last year
into 2021. madison kimbrough joins us
live in the newsroom tonight with this
story in madison
i hear many couples are choosing to
elope yeah sasha it's true in a time
where the world is filled with stress
due to this pandemic
many couples have found that eloping is
an easier option and while many of us
have
to social distance ourselves from many
loved ones it's making more people want
to be together
and make it official it's just nice to
actually get out and see people do
things and
feel like some amount of normalcy again
emily and her soon-to-be husband ryan
will say i do on sunday
and while couples flocking to las vegas
to get married is nothing new
there has been a coveted wedding boom
going on and clark county along with
wedding venue companies are noticing
that elopements
seem to be all the rage ever since
the vaccinations have let people start
to travel again
we have just been bombarded uh
we are up over 2019
which was already a very good year for
us i think what's happening this year is
that there's such a backlog
of weddings because people had to
postpone postponed postpone or delay
that now people are thinking maybe i
should just actually elope so
we are seeing numbers and uptick in
numbers for sure
people like robert say they've been
planning for this day for some time now
and now just feels like the right time
to make it official
we have a chapel set up this evening and
we're going to have the marriage
ceremony there
just a small little get together and
then we'll have a larger wedding at a
more relaxed time in regards to the the
coveted lockdowns
owner of cactus collective weddings
mackenzie taylor says
while she has seen a rise in interest
she's finding that more people are
looking to elope as venues are still so
hard to find
the people were postponing for so long
that
now it's just like the surplus of people
that were engaged
so there's no venues there's no
resources for people to actually have
their wedding
and some interesting information we
learned from the marriage licensing
bureau
due to heavy backups several california
residents have been coming down here
to get their licenses a much quicker way
so they don't have to wait
months at a time in california due to
cova delays
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now